wait
um thank you for
the invitation and for the introduction
and also welcome to everyone from ifml
to the assignment Workshop I have one of
the coordinators for the data driven
decision making decision process program
semester it's great to have your and
hopefully you can talk to many of the
other semester participants and find out
about what we are working
um
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
and actually this talk is maybe a bit of
an example of what this entire program
is about so I'm going to talk about
online decision making but in particular
a large part of the program we've been
thinking about our bank decision making
and how we come up with algorithms which
adapt better to it's a problem instances
so if the problem is simple how do we
get better bounds and how do we sort of
get worst case Bonds in general uh I'll
talk about one particular technique
which I've been started looking at over
the last four or five years this idea of
using a company in particular using this
idea of the compensation company and I
try to convince you why in some sense in
many of these online decision making
problems uh thinking about the future is
actually the best since we're taking
decisions about the present uh and my
plan for this talk is instead of telling
you what is sorry
um so my plan for this talk is instead
of talking about
sort of the best of what we can do with
this technique I'll I'll instead just
focus on a very very simple problem and
try to illustrate exactly how this
technique works so I'll actually try to
go into a proof and go through it in all
its gory details uh this is going to be
a very simple setting for using this but
the hope is that towards the end of the
talk maybe I'll talk a bit about like
how this extends to other settings and
kind of point you to some talks next
week which will go into more details and
the simple setting I'm going to talk
about is this one so this is a problem
which I have meditated on for like the
last four or five years and I still keep
thinking about it all the time so it's
what I call the online unit online unit
demand knocks out so the idea is you are
as a principal you start off with some
fixed resource so maybe you have three
units of a resource at the beginning and
then you have a set of arriving agents
each of whom has a value see the TF
agent has some value VT and when the
agent comes you need to either decide to
accept the agent in which case you use
up one unit of the resource or you can
reject the agent in which case you don't
have use up any resource but you don't
get the guys party and you can only
accept up to B agents which was your
initial budget
so so that's sort of
example I want to think about and the
reason I want to think about this I
actually think of this as sort of one of
the simplest test cases for thinking
about online decision making in some
sense like whenever you have something
new which you feel is a better algorithm
for some very complicated setting if it
does not do better than what we know
here well maybe go back and think again
but but a lot of inside like this
setting sort of simplifies everything
down to the Bare Bones and you get a lot
of insight from just wondering about it
now some of you may think about this
setting and say well okay I've not
specified where the values come from but
suppose the values came from some known
distribution well then this is a really
really simple markup decision process
it's a one-dimensional markup decision
process
I'm sure most of you if you try you so
very quickly be able to actually write
out a closed form solution for what is
optimal so it's a little odd that we
still think so much about it but inside
one reason for thinking about it so many
of you are at this point wanting to give
up and say okay this is too simple I I
don't want to think about this but
here's the sort of generalization of
this problem which already brings in a
lot of the complexities of General mdp
so what if instead of having one
research I have B different Resources
with sort of different initial budgets
B1 B2 up to BB and now each agent still
offers me some value VI but in addition
they also want some subset of resources
so the story at least in operations
research is you're trying to take a
flight from A to B but there's no direct
flight you have to take a one-hub flight
you need both the tickets in order to
buy by this and you again want to
allocate these resources while obeying
the resource constraints over time uh in
order to try and maximize your Revenue
um the problem now is this this is
already this is a very small extension
of the online Maps act but you already
start getting What's called the curse of
dimensionality so in particular the size
of the state space if you just write
this down as an MVP is something like
order t to the D plus one and now if you
try using your favorite reinforcement
learning algorithm it'll work eventually
but it's going to give some sort of a
baroque solution it will take forever
it's not very interesting
does this make sense so so this is so I
want to think about the simpler problem
but you know with an eye towards
something which looks more complicated
like this uh
and one problem with working with
something complicated like this is well
if I don't even know what the optimal
solution looks like or if the optimal
solution is this complicated how do I
even reason about it and the way that
people have been reasoning about it in
in computer science and operations
research
um for a long time is thinking instead
about a benchmark which is easier to
compute so I want some upper Bound for
this problem which may not be the
optimal solution but which is somehow
guaranteed to be an upper bar and here
is the simplest upper bound you can
think of which is well what if I told
you all the arrivals what would you do
in this case this is just now I mean in
the case of the single the unit demand
knapsack the solution is obvious you
sort all the values and pick the top B
so what I've written over here is that
the optimal solution is just the sum of
the baith largest value so the baith
largest order statistics of this
distribution of the arrivals but even
more generally even if I gave you the
online packing problem you could still
Define this object you can solve an
integer program and that would give you
the optimal solution
right so
the question that we are interested in
is for problems of this sort uh can I
come up with some kind of nice Benchmark
for the optimal solution and then can I
try and come up with some nice algorithm
which does well compared to this
Benchmark in an additive sense so what
is the additive loss compared to this
benchmark
and this is a problem for the particular
case of unit demand maps and this is
actually been studied for a really long
time so uh
the literature on this goes back all the
way back to the 80s uh we knew what the
optimal solution was but there was still
this beautiful set of work by Helen cuts
and also as the Samuel carbon they
thought about this problem for just a
single item so it's sort of the simplest
setting of this but came up with really
like much simpler algorithms than the
optimal which was still within a
constant factor of the optimum so they
got a constant factor of whatever the
optimal MVP solution was getting and and
these ideas have been generalized
extensively by the TCS community in like
the last 10 to 12 years uh to a very
wide variety of settings and actually we
have a lot of people in the program who
are experts on thinking about these
processes on like on matrides on on all
sorts of sort of complicated constraint
sets and trying to come up with these
kind of constant Factor algorithms uh
this is amazing however there is a
problem that
all of this works extremely well if you
have a small number of items as you
increase the number of items like
getting a constant Factor basically
means your regret is scaling with the
number of items so if your number of
items is on the order of the Horizon
that's not great you don't want to lose
half your Revenue if you're selling a
lot of things uh there are better
answers for this I I mean you can't show
the competitive ratio slightly better
than this but morally the the regret is
still scaling with the parameters of the
property now there's a different line of
work coming more from the operations
research and the applied probability
domains where what people have been
thinking of is instead of having these
kind of completely arbitrary like
distributions you you fix the arrival
process and make the arrival process
independent of the Horizon so one simple
example of this is well what if we had
IID arrivals from some known
distribution you still want to ask this
question about okay how well how well
can you solve the online packing problem
compared to the offline Optimum and
there we've again this has also been
studied for right now on 30 years and we
essentially know that in a regime like
this so regret you can get is something
like square root T now y square root T
should make sense is well if if you just
think about the setting without the
constraints uh this is the uncertainty
just coming from the central limit
theorem on what these values are and and
what what these results are effectively
saying is you can always get a regret on
the order of the central limit theorem
you can actually do better than that so
this was a amazing result by Marty
Raymond and Chiang one back in 2008 but
they proved that there should be an
algorithm which does strictly better
than square root T and in some but we
couldn't kind of figure out exactly what
that should be in or there wasn't a
clean way to understand it uh later on
Jason and Kumar showed that there were
ways of like if you kind of remove some
subset of inputs so under a certain
condition called dual number degeneracy
uh you could get a constant regret a
regret which didn't even depend on the
parameters but but as as you went closer
to these sort of degenerate instances
you again went back to square root 10.
this is sort of where things were back
in like 2015 or so uh
so this is Sir where
I started thinking of this problem I'm
kind of the strange question I wanted to
think about was well what if you fix
this arrival process so for example what
if I say that I have a finite set of
values and each value VI arise with some
probability Pi ID and these pis have
nothing to do with these are just
numbers given to you and now I scale
both T and B so I make the problem
bigger and bigger in terms of the state
space I have larger Horizons I have
larger budgets but I'm freezing the
remaining parameters of the problem I'm
not sort of taking this dual limit so
what what is the best regret you can get
in a domain like this and surprisingly
the answer is that at least for the
online maps are
um under any arrival process over a
finite type space uh there is a very
simple algorithm which actually has
regret which is a constant it does not
scale at all with the budget or the time
Horizon in fact you can give very simple
ex like expressions for what for an
upper bound on the regret this is far
from being tight but but what it's
saying is okay it depends on the maximum
value it depends on these IID
probabilities which are fixed up front
of course if you change the probability
that if you make them dependent on T
this bond is it's not as strong but but
once you fix everything your regret is
utmost this it has nothing to do with
the budget or the time process
so something
interesting is happening in these
problems which is making them much
easier than what we believed was true
and what I and pretty much since then so
okay firstly some of you may think this
is just Theory but no this is actually
true in practice so these algorithms are
incredibly useful like if you try just
using them compared to what existed in
the state of the art uh what I'm doing
here is I'm taking this is a online
packing problem with with mult in higher
Dimensions I am basically now scaling
the budget and I'm scaling the time
Horizon and looking at the regret so
these were sort of the state of the art
algorithms that we knew this is roughly
a square root T regret this is what we
get that there's just no sort of Tricks
going on over here you just there's a
small change in the algorithm which kind
of immediately collapses the regret all
the way down here uh and most of what
we've been thinking about since then at
least in the OR Community has been sort
of taking this as a primitive and then
thinking about okay how far can you push
it how far can you push these uh
assumptions what else can you do Etc so
so my aim today is going to be to
try and talk a little bit about how we
get this and what are the techniques
which led to it but I just wanted to
show all of this to you know what
motivate you all in case like I'm gonna
go deep into the weeds of the maths
after this but
just want to make sure everyone's
somewhat interested in the week so any
questions in this point
no so no they put actually scale and
completely arbitrary rates uh so there
was a intermediate result when the
budget over time is a constant when
actually there was a parallel result to
us which showed that in that regime
something else was doing well actually
none of that market the budget of the
time can scale any way they want
okay so I'm hoping I've got you're
sufficiently interested to spend the
next 20 minutes getting into the weeds
of this and uh so what I want to talk to
you about is as promised the compensated
coupling which is essentially a
different way of thinking about these
problems which leads to these results uh
and several of you have seen this before
or Okay so
some of you have seen this before but
for everyone else uh this is the main
idea this kind of the high level idea of
what's going on in the coupling so the
idea is that you have two controllers
um and think of this as an online
controller which is the algorithm that's
going ahead and taking certain actions
and then you have some sort of offline
controller which knows the entire
history so which knows exactly what's
coming in the future and is taking
decisions based on this information so
what I want to do and regret is I want
to compare how well the online
controller does with the offline uh the
important thing about this offline
controller is because it knows the
future I can sort of throw the offline
controller in some bizarre state in the
middle like you can think of one of
these like like choose your own Mystery
kind of books where you go into the
middle and then you are in some strange
State and the offline still knows what's
the right thing to do in order to reach
the future because who knows the future
and I want to know how to compare the
two and here's the idea of creating the
coupling so I'm going to follow a single
sample part so I will run one simulation
of this problem and I'll
follow these two algorithms until the
first time when one of this algorithms
the in particular the offline algorithm
wants to do something different from the
online algorithm so this is the first
time when these two are separating out
and what I'll do at this instance is I'm
going to force the offline algorithm to
give up on what it wanted to do and
instead follow the online algorithm now
of course the offline algorithm isn't
happy at this process because it knows
that by taking this action it's going to
lose out in the future on this sample
path
but I'm somehow going to try and figure
out a random variable which would
compensate the offline for taking this
action at this point
so this is going to be the main idea so
let me actually formalize this a bit so
here is the same thing in a little more
gory math so what I really mean by an
online and offline controller is I have
two different algorithms which have
different data available to it so when I
say a richer filtration and a natural
filtration that is probably speak for
saying what is the data available to the
algorithm when it's making its decision
so the natural filtration is whatever
data you've seen up till now the history
of the process a richer filtration is
something which has extra data data
about the future in order to make its
decisions
uh and at any time now given this these
data sets I can Define the value that
like at any time and any state I can
Define the value that the online
algorithm and the offline algorithm will
get for if I start at the back State at
that time so for the online algorithm
this is exactly a value function this is
the value the expected value if you
follow this policy from now on to the
Future for the offline it's something a
little more complicated so in the case
where GP is like the full data set if
you know all future values this would
exactly be the sort of exposed value of
the optimal solution starting from that
state
does this make sense what these objects
are but but these are both random
variables because they sort of depend on
the sample path and the filtrations uh
and now here's kind of
the the way to formalize what I said in
the previous slides I'm following the
online algorithm so everything in green
is as as seen by an online algorithm and
I reach a certain State and at this
stage offline and online are taking
different actions and they're going to
different points
so what I want to do is I want to
somehow Force the offline guy to not
take this orange action but instead take
the green action and I need to
compensate the offline for this process
so formally what this means is the
offline is thinking about getting its
value function from the state onward
and instead of allowing it to do so I
will force it to take the action that
online is taking at which point it's
going to get some instantaneous reward
it's going to transition exactly the
same way as the online algorithm
transition so get the value function of
the next state as of the next state of
the online algorithm and then there's
some random variable in between which
would sort of compensate the left hand
side and the right hand side like the
left hand side should be bigger than the
right hand side but I'm adding this blue
Delta in order to make sure that it's
not
why is this nice well I can keep oh yeah
go ahead
excellent
like why does why why you passed in the
offline if you know a state yeah
I mean in more complicated settings
this means I know everything online
knows plus the future there are examples
where you need the password in this one
yeah we can
okay but at this point what I'm now
going to do is when I have an equation
of this one I can just telescope it so I
can just follow online along the sample
path and if I telescope it what you're
going to get is something like the
solvent so as you the V offline on both
sides keep canceling out until all
you're left with is be offline in the
initial term and the sum of all the
rewards which is exactly what we online
got on the sample path uh and the
difference of the two is the summation
of all these compensations but the
difference of the two by definition is
the regret of this process
so is there for the smallest number no
any number which is guaranteed to be the
rate of motion yeah
does this make sense okay good so
so if this seemed too weird and
unfamiliar um at least for any of you
who have seen reinforcement learning you
would have seen some version of this
before so if you've ever seen the
performance difference dilemma of
crocodile method that's a special case
of the compensated coupling where you
think about both the policies as having
the same filtration so if both the
policies are adapted to the Natural
filtration then when you add this up
what you basically get is you're looking
at the value function of some policy Pi
hat with respect to the sample paths
taken by policy Pi which exactly works
out to be the sort of sample path
average of What's called the advantage
function of this policy this didn't make
sense not very important but um it just
so turns out that like at least in
reinforcement learning this is kind of
one of the workers things that you use
for most of the analysis for any of you
who came to Kevin and Andrew's talk on
on Wednesday um they were sort of using
this and doing kind of amazing things
with it but this is just a natural
conclusion of this this coupling if you
just feed in the natural filtration
uh but I'm kind of insisting on using a
richer filtration so
so why am I doing that what's like what
do we get if I use the Richer filtration
and this is going to get me back to the
question about
the online unit demand knapsack so what
I now want to show you in the remaining
10 minutes or so is
how can we like I've set up this
coupling this is a general way of giving
us bounds for any online decision making
process but but the ability to somehow
peek into the future actually gives us
much stronger Bonds in certain cases I
will try to illustrate this very
literally
um so remember this was my online unit
demand Maps I can what I'm now assuming
is that the value at each time is drawn
from some known CDF capitals it's known
from drawn from some known distribution
and I still want to maximize the sum of
the reports uh
and for the moment just just for
Simplicity let's even assume that the
CDF is the uniform on zero one so I'm
drawing values from uniform zero one and
I want to try and maximize the reward
and I've sort of plonked you down on
this problem somewhere in the middle
where I have h plus 1 times steps left
and I have some budget small B something
has happened in the future forget about
the future doesn't matter now what's
going to happen at this point is if I go
and ask offline hey what's what's the
largest like what's the sort of your
value from now till the future he's
going to say well I'm going to pick the
B largest arrivals in the remaining age
in the future
uh and I'm going to call this quantity V
of the the BS largest I'll call it V of
H minus B and that's some point between
0 and 1.
now I don't know this I don't know
what's coming in the future I need to
decide what to do with the current
arrival uh
so what I'm going to do as a is I'll
choose some like some point Theta and if
the current arrival is bigger than that
I'll accept it else I'll reject now if
you think a bit about what the offline
guy is doing this was the baith largest
thing in the future if the current
arrival was bigger than this he would
have accepted it if it was smaller than
this he would have rejected it
so what this really means is in these
two regions on either side we actually
have no compensation we both completely
agree the the offline agent with extra
information on me as an online agent
without knowing the future know exactly
what the right value is
so some of the only uncertainties
happening in this little region in
between the my threshold and the H minus
BM and you can sort of reverse the same
thing and say okay what if Theta was
bigger and you'll get almost a similar
picture
okay um and at this point I can actually
directly calculate the compensation
because if the current arrival is some
value over here and I accept it then I
need to give up on this value in the
future and so my compensation is exactly
the difference of the two
and you can kind of again think about
this thing when Theta and V are reverse
and you'll get something very similar so
sort of this is my compensation
condition on knowing the future value
and without knowing the current file or
if the current value is C and if I
average over the current value so if I
average over VT I'm basically paying the
length of this distance under the just
the bag measure since I have a uniform
distribution which is basically we the
this VHB minus Theta the whole Square
basically the square of this interval
it's just simple geometry
okay so I somehow need to be able to
understand this like all of this is
conditioned on knowing the H minus B of
the future for the uniform you can now
kind of simply just solve this because
we know everything about other
statistics but how do I do it for a
General Distribution what what even is
the right policy for a General
Distribution so here's the policy that I
had proposed with Alberto back in like
2018 now so this is what we call the
base selector and the idea was that well
suppose I knew the CDF at some time T if
I have like small like at Small Time
small team this is the time to go
um let me look at my normalized budget
so budget divided by the remaining time
so project that onto the CDF and then
look at what the threshold is
that is our natural boundary to decide
whether to accept or reject if my
current value is higher than that I
accept otherwise I reject there's sort
of a
small but really really important
tiebreaking issues so what happens if my
boundary Falls in between and it the
right thing to do is then to actually
snap to the the closer point so you sort
of divide it right in between and then
decide so here the threshold is V here
the threshold is sort of V minus
this is surprisingly critical but but we
know what to do
okay so that's my threshold how do I
analyze it how do I figure out the
compensation well
here is the idea so in order to figure
out the compensation suppose I told you
what the future samples were so in
Orange I'm drawing out what all the
future samples were from now till the
end of time
and
one thing you can clearly see from this
is if you just draw the empirical CDF
with like height one over T minus t
you'll kind of see that in future I
would have been accepting this this and
this sample these are the three things
which would have fit into my budget just
just by drawing the CDF and extending
out this the remaining budget
so the only place again that I'm making
a mistake is in this little region here
if my current arrival Falls in this
little region over here I make a mistake
anywhere else I don't actually pay a
compensation compared to the Future
it's exactly the same as what I did with
the uniform but now just looking at the
general geometry of these trusts
so I somehow need to understand how to
bound the probability of falling in
between or the square of this distance
but that's usually a tricky thing to do
I mean it's very hard to think about
what's the probability of falling in
this region under a General Distribution
however I can project it onto the y-axis
and instead think about gaps between my
cdfs
it's not totally clear why that's easier
but but as long as this this curve is
it's some it's lip shits I can convert
distances on the x axis to distances on
the y-axis and so look at the CDF uh
and now here is the same compensation
argument as before so I'm again trying
to integrate this the probability of
falling in the or the length of this
region under now this distribution small
f
suppose this distribution was upper
bounded by some capital M well I can
just bound this by m times the square of
the link this was exactly what I had
done before I don't know how to analyze
the square of this distance for some
General Distribution but as long as the
distribution is anti-concentrated so if
it's bounded below by some small M well
it's at most the sort of worst case
length or the worst case distance
between the empirical CDF and the true
CDF
this didn't make sense it's just algebra
there's nothing fancy going on all I've
said is I can write down the
compensation that I pay at each time at
least for well behaved random variables
in terms of the distance between some
empirical CDF and some true CDF
and everything up to now has been
Elementary in some sense and this is the
only time when you need a slightly
heavier Hammer but any one of you who
does like online learning or applied
probability will kind of know that this
object is actually extremely well
behaved so the empirical CDF and the
true CDF for any distribution is
uniformly bounded or it's uniformly
concentrated um the result which is
often called the bkw or the risky for
Wolf of its inequality the sort of
particular numerical form is due to
massage
and at this point I'm done like all the
calculations are done before just for
the uniform distribution I can just Port
it over because I know how to analyze
the difference between my cdfs and
basically if you just do a little bit of
algebra you'll get this is essentially 1
over T minus t when you add it up you
get a long T regret
so just an elementary coupling plus this
one non-trivial uniform concentration
bound allows you to show that for any
distribution here which is at least
anti-concentrated
um you should get a log T regret and and
actually you can kind of see why you can
use this to analyze anything else so as
an example if your distribution wasn't
even bound or if it wasn't even on a
compact set but let's say it's sub
exponential or it's monotone Hazard rate
you can kind of turn through the same
machinery and you will get other
constants that show up and you'll still
get log T regret in each of these cases
yes
what
questions
uh
Smalling no the small lamp here
oh and yes over here this is the number
of arrivals in the future so it's the
number of things you're using to compute
the senior or the empirical CDF so the
empirical CDF is drawn using eight
samples in the future
so let me show you one last little magic
tricks okay something something algebra
why is this useful uh here's another
thing you could have asked which is well
what if the F was unknown so many of you
think about or at least must have been
thinking about it you assume the f is
known well what if it's just IID
and the natural thing to do would be
well do the same thing just use the
plugin estimate so just take the T
samples up up till now look at that
empirical CDF do exactly the same thing
that I described
um well how well does this do
but instead of asking how how much does
this lose compared to offline
I can sort of because the computations
are they're sort of composable I can
instead compare against the algorithm
that I already analyzed online with the
known CDF I already know this is log T
away from the offline so if I could
prove this is also log T away from this
new this empirical version of the
algorithm I would have got a two log T
Bond but I claim this is immediate
because actually it's the same problem
in Reverse so what did we earlier
analyze we sort of looked at a known CDF
and an empirical distribution but that's
actually exactly what I'm looking at now
nothing has changed it's just like
Looking Backward versus looking forward
is the same analysis you can again do
the same in fact you can do an even more
general statement which is well whatever
analysis you had for the forward regret
if you use the plugin estimator you just
get twice of that for the backward for
the unknown distribution so kind of
what's more powerful about this
technique is well firstly it let you do
this more detailed calculation but but
it also sort of just naturally extends
to other things which you may want to do
so in the last 20 seconds I'm I hope
I've got somewhat interested in this
technique
um and you may be thinking okay does
this go beyond
just the online unit demand knapsack or
or have have we wasted half an hour just
thinking about this one very simple
problem but uh luckily it goes far
beyond so as an example um
you may be interested in something like
online Vector bin packing a much much
harder problem one which we had very
little idea of what to do Beyond a
square root T regret but in work with
Daniel Frank we showed that if you just
look at online Vector bin parking with
sort of arrivals under under mild
assumptions you again get an algorithm
which has constant loss compared to the
offline and this is in log plot what I'm
showing are existing algorithms which
have some polynomial laws and here is is
effectively constant class module with
some noise uh
no no no so I'm saying jobs are coming
in I can create bins I want to minimize
the number of bins I use to pack these
jobs into the risk so this problem yeah
I mean even the offline problem is NP
hard but if you scale T it's not and
then this becomes you get a constant
regret
uh
you can sort of extend it to other
bizarre things like doing online pricing
if any of you are interested in Dynamic
pricing you also have constant regret
algorithms for dynamic pricing
um I'm not going to say much more
because luckily for me this gentleman in
between is going to actually give a much
longer talk on these more advanced
things so please look out for this on
Monday and I will stop thank you
[Applause]
degrees and so we reconvene in eight
minutes